okay so everyone my name is and this is
the long form version of the
presentation of our paper decision
making under this calibration for itcs
2023.
this is Joint work with guy off no
variables
okay so our focus on this work is on a
setting that we call from predictions to
decisions
what do I mean by predictions basically
we suppose that we have a universe of
individuals X say given by the
covariance or features and we have
access to some risk predictor so
basically a mapping from every
individual to a value in zero uh in the
interval zero one so for example we want
to estimate
um this person's risk of having a
cardiovascular event in some certain
foil period
by decisions I mean that the way we end
up using this predictor p is to inform
multiple Downstream binary decision
problems okay these can be buried for
example should a specific individual be
prescribe some medication should they be
subject to symmetrical medical treatment
Etc
okay and for this talk I'm gonna call
all of these decisions uh treat or don't
treat decisions but this is just because
I have this medical example in mind
okay so basically we will instantiate
this in a utility-based framework so we
suppose that we have the distribution D
over individual and binary outcome kits
as I mentioned we have this risk
predictor p a treatment threshold would
just be a number J in the interval 0 1
where we understand that if a person's
risk predicted risk is above the
threshold then they receive a prediction
of one
and at Downstream binary decision would
just be parameterized by its cost
structure so think of this as the
relative costs of making say correct
versus incorrect predictions right false
positive true positives Etc
so basically all of these uh this
quadruple of costs the distribution the
predictor and the threshold together
this determines some notion of utility
from treatment
and a concept that I'll be referring to
is that we say that the treatment is
harmful if the utility actually ends up
being lower than the utility that you
could have obtained without using the
predictor at all right so even if we
don't have any risk prediction you can
always just decide to either treat
everyone or treat no one that also gives
you some notion of utility so one
Benchmark certainly is that we don't
want to be worse than what these two
strategies whatever this would be a
harmful treatment
okay
so for us the decision making problem is
basically uh given the cost structure
the distribution and the predictor that
we now think of as just six how do we
determine the treatment pressure
okay and there's an existing but partial
answer to this question which is that if
the predictor in question is perfectly
calibrated then there is a threshold
that also known as J star in the
literature it's called a therapeutic
threshold that guarantees that
thresholding P at J star will cause no
harm in the sense that I've mentioned
before
and kind of the nice thing about this
threshold is that it completely uh does
not depend on both the distribution and
the predictor in question so it's just a
function of the cost structure in
question
and here the requirement for perfect
calibration basically means that for
every possible risk value B if you look
at all the individuals whose prediction
was precisely this value V and you look
at their eventual outcomes under the
distribution D then precisely the
refraction of those outcomes are
positive
okay so this is perfect calorie position
um but unfortunately this is a partial
answer because it breaks down under
miscalibration okay this has already
been shown in some earlier work for
example uh caster and Vickers actually
show through simulations that if you
start with a calibrated predictor but
then you gradually induce miscalibration
then eventually and and it even happens
uh fairly fast you can make trading at
this therapeutic threshold J star
actually harmful
um
okay
so let's start talking about decision
making basically this selection of
threshold under miscalibration when we
do anticipate that the predictor that we
have access to is not necessarily
perfectly calibrated
okay so here I'm I'm denoting a case
where the therapeutic threshold J star
is 0.05 as I've mentioned this kind of
already tells me something about the
cost structure of the problem that we
have in mind here specifically right
intuitively it makes sense the threshold
is low it means that the benefit that I
would expect from making true positive
predictions so really identifying the
people who need treatment is much
greater than the harm that I would
anticipate I'll receive from making
incorrect uh treatment decisions
okay so let's look at say the collection
of women who have a prediction of say
0.04 so slightly under a therapeutic
expression do I want to treat them or do
I not want to treat them
so if the predictor was perfectly
calibrated also on this sub-population
of women then I know the answer right I
don't want to treat them because on
average this group would not benefit
from treatment
but what happens under miscalibration
now it's a bit less obvious right I can
use the therapeutic threshold J star but
if I then find out that my predictor was
underestimating the risk in this group
then I would actually end up regretting
not treating these people
um on the other hand if I'm tempted to
then use a lower threshold but then I
found out that my predictor was actually
overestimating the risk in women then I
might regret having treated these
individuals okay so the point here is
that there are competing concerns and a
priori is not clear how to balance them
because kind of the the stuff the errors
that I can see under a certain bound of
alpha miscalibration don't really have a
symmetric effect here because of the
fact that the very nature of this
decision problem is that it's asymmetric
right the cost structure is not exactly
the same
okay
so I want to argue that this question of
um looking at the impact of decisions on
protected demographic subgroups is also
a practically uh relevant uh concern and
indeed there's been some earlier work
this is just one example by a study by
Collins and Atman basically showing that
the farming home risk score which is a
very popular risk score for estimating
cardiovascular risk
um if you look at it at a uh do an
evaluation at a British cohort then they
showed that it overestimates the risk in
women
which indeed results in a harmful model
if you end up using it for thresholds 20
or higher okay so these kinds of
concerns really arise in practice
um at this point something you might ask
is okay what about multi-calibration
right if we know that calibration is
important and we know that we care about
the impact of what happens to subsets of
the population then we might want to
ensure ahead of time with the predictor
we're using is multi-calibrated
okay well this is definitely true and
something that's important to do in this
case it doesn't entirely solve the
problem because in practice we would
always have a finite number of training
samples also for this procedure of
multi-calibration and presumably a rich
Class C
so while multi-calibration would allow
us to get kind of a an overall bound on
the maximum calibration error over these
subgroups this Bond would not
necessarily be very close to zero so
some calibration errors are inevitable
and there is still the question of how
these are potentially Amplified in the
decision making process
okay so this is the the starting point
for our one
so basically you can think of it in the
following way the question that we put
forth is if J star or this therapeutic
threshold is as we know the optimal
threshold you would apply to a perfectly
calibrated risk particular irrespective
of the distribution and the specifics of
the predictor is there kind of a
similarly optimal threshold j-hat that
you should be applying if you know
you're faced with an imperfectly
calibrated predictor
okay so this is our high level motivated
question and of course it raises a lot
of kind of follow-up questions we want
to instantiate this framework
specifically which solution concept do
we use here to determine optimality in
this new context and then what is this
threshold actually end up looking and is
it even different from J star and when
um okay so I'll I'll give an kind of a
general overview of a result and then
I'll I'll say a bit more in the next two
slides
um first of all regarding the solution
concept that we use we Define a notion
of regret under bounded miscalibration
and then we proposed that the threshold
you should use is in some sense the
Minimax threshold we want to minimize
the maximal regret that you can obtain
under bounded miscalibration
um in terms of what this threshold
actually looks like our main kind of
technical effort is to show that this
optimization problem actually has a
simple close from close form solution we
have a different a bunch of different
ones depending on how you actually
choose to measure miscalibration
and interestingly our results show that
this new threshold differs from the
therapeutic rational Json
precisely for decision problems that
have very asymmetric costs so I'll
discuss it in a bit but you can think of
it as kind of providing a rigorous
explanation for this behavior that seems
intuitive which is that we want to be in
some sense conservative under the
uncertainty that's induced by the
miscalibration
Okay so
to say a bit more from a technical
perspective about this regret uh
minimization uh approach so basically
given a cost structure and a
distribution D Prime
per predictor P Prime we say that the
regret that you obtain from thresholding
it at J1 rather than a J2 is just the
difference in utilities from the utility
that you would get from thresholding a
J2 versus J1
okay so this is relatively
straightforward now the main component
is that we look at a kind of worst case
version of this regret so basically if
you want to use a threshold J what's the
worst that could happen under this
setting
so we take the maximum over both any
potential other threshold that we could
have used J Prime and most importantly
over all the pairs of predictors and
distributions that conform to this
calibration error constraint so
basically the calibration error of P
Prime when evaluated on the distribution
D Prime should be at most Alpha okay and
then we look at the regret in this case
so putting it all together our solution
concept J hat give men a specific cost
structure and a parameter Alpha that we
use to denote kind of the anticipated
level of miscalibration that we might
expect to see is we should use the
threshold that minimizes this maximal
regret
okay and two important components uh
first of all by Design we made this
solution concept also distribution free
like the therapeutic threshold right
that neither the distribution nor the
predictor in question appear here for J
Prime because they're already kind of
implicitly apart in this worst case
optimization problem
um and the second uh remark is that
while we can very cleanly State this
optimization problem it's not
necessarily clear what does it tell us
about the solution J hat right like in
in case in principle this is a Minimax
uh problem over an exponential Subspace
so
as I mentioned the the main technical
effort in our paper is to show that you
can actually obtain a simple close form
expressions for this uh threshold j-hub
we do this under two Notions of
approximate miscalibration the details
are less important but these are both
popular Notions one is the expected
calibration error and the other is the
maximum calibration error and basically
to do this we utilize the fact that uh
as it turns out this worst case regrets
that I've discussed before
always ends up being maximized by a very
specific predictor okay actually a
predictor that is only supported on at
most two levels and then for this
restricted class of predictors we can
actually analyze things directly so it
becomes a bit more easier
Okay so
visually this is how things look like so
here I'm plotting the
threshold J hat as a function of jstock
to show the comparison between J star
and J hat and we can see that kind of
for intermediate values of J star so
think of it as decision problems that
don't have
um and particularly asymmetric cost
structure
Jihad is just identical to J star but on
the other way on the other hand as we
near the edges the behavior is kind of
more extreme leaning towards a more
conservative side of just treating
everyone or treating no one depending on
um
exactly the cost structure okay so as I
mentioned before this is kind of a
rigorous explanation for this sort of
intuitive behavior that we might expect
which is that you want to be more
conservative given the asymmetric nature
of the decision problem
okay
so one important uh point I want to
mention is about this uh choice of the
worst case regret so one thing that
probably stood out to you is that we
essentially assumed in the way we
formalized the the objective that we
don't know anything about either the
predictor the distribution or this
collection of sets when we actually end
up uh choosing the therapeutic that's
threshold uh right but in in practice
there may be cases where this is not the
situation maybe we just have a single
fixed predictor in mind and we want to
use a threshold that actually depends on
it maybe we have a fixed collection of
sets in mind maybe we assume that we
have access to unlabeled examples when
we actually do the thresholding
procedure and there are a bunch of
different other variations
um in this sense it's a bit similar to
literature on domain adaptation right
where we can kind of go from not
assuming anything about what we know
about the new distribution as opposed to
building in some more assumptions
um so technically these assumptions are
very easy to build into our framework
right you just need to define the same
notion of maximal regret but take the
maximum with respect to a more
restricted class of predictor and
distribution pairs for example but then
you end up with a much more potentially
more challenging optimization problem
right so I'm just putting it out here to
say it's very natural to ask what
happens when we make this addition these
additional assumptions uh right does the
effect of miscalibration change I think
it's an interesting direction for
additional one
um and just to wrap up with another I
think high level uh discussion Point
basically in this work we showed that
even slight miscalibration might require
taking this fact into account in the
subsequent stages of the pipeline
specifically how we translate risk
predictions to Binary decisions
I think more generally it's helpful to
think about things in this way so
breaking down this you know algorithmic
decision making problem into the steps
and the stages that it consists of and I
think this is very useful because kind
of it allows us to start thinking also
from a theoretical and rigorous
perspective about how these different
stages might end up impacting each other
okay so for example it can suggest
useful in the city radar for the earlier
stages right here we basically kind of
showed another reason for why I want
risk predictors that are more
decalibrated
um but it can also suggest different
behavior for what you want to do in the
later stages of the pipeline depending
on what we anticipate kind of went wrong
in the earlier stages
so in some sense I think what we did
here is one specific instantiation of a
much more General problem that I think
can be a useful component in kind of
thinking theoretically about this uh
high level objective of reliable
Computing or reliable decision making
um so that's it thank you very much and
happy uh to have more follow-up
discussions